crypto is going to be Mass adopted and
it's already being Mass adopted we see
MasterCard Visa loads of different
payment intermediaries PayPal whatever
it is adopting crypto and and allowing
people to use it but I think that it's
not going to go down a good route and by
that I mean I see governments creating
their own crypto which would be a
central bank digital currency and that
is basically a cryptocurrency but it's
also like the fiat currency that we have
now so it's just like a digital dollar
which is programmable and so governments
have the ability to program the money so
they can decide how people spend that
money like with all technology it's all
very exciting at first but it can then
be harnessed and used for the worst and
that's where I see the crypto space
going unfortunately